الامتثال المكره سابقه تكبدتها اسرائيل
بخضوعها غير المسبوق للمسائله على وقع مضي
100 يوم من حربها الداميه على غزه لم تعتد
تل ابيب ابدا النزول تحت خط المحاسبه بفضل
ستار الحمايه الامريكي والغربي المرخي
عليها نحو ثمانيه عقود الدعوه التي رفعتها
جنوب افريقيا دون شريك من اشقاء غزه
الاقربين احدثت دويا عالميا وقلقا
اسرائيليا عمي
في اعقاب تاسيس دولتها ساهمت اسرائيل
بحفاوه في تاسيس اتفاقيه منع الاباده
الجماعيه لملاحقه النازيين لكنها وجدت
نفسها اليوم في قفص الاتهام نفسه الفريق
القانوني لجنوب افريقيا خطف الانظار ليس
فقط برمز تاريخ مناهضه بلاده للعنصريه بل
لمرافعة الماضيه عرضت اسرائيل غزه لما
اعتبرت اكثف حمله قصف في تاريخ الحروب
المعاصره في 4 صفحه اسست جنوب افريقيا
دعواها غير المسبوقه على ان ممارسات جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في قطاع غزه طوال نحو
100 يوم تشكل جريمه اباده جماعيه
لارتكابها بالقصد المحدد لتدمير
الفلسطينيين في القطاع والقصد المحدد هو
ما سيكون على ادعاء جنوب افريقيا اثباته
امام المحكمه بالنظر لاتفاقيه منع جريمه
الاباده الجماعيه المعتمده امميا في
التاسع من ديسمبر عام
1948 والتي اشترطت مادتها الثانيه التوفر
الكلي او الجزئي لقصد اباده جماعه ما على
اساس قومي او عرقي او جنسي او ديني
بالاقدام على قتل اعضاء من الجماعه او
الحاق اذى جسدي او روحي خطير باعضاء منها
او اخضاع الجماعه عمدا لظروف معيشيه يراد
بها تدميرها المادي كليا او جزئيا او فرض
تدابير تستهدف الحيلوله دون انجاب الاطفال
داخل الجماعه او نقل اطفال من الجماعه
عنوه الى جماعه اخرى القصد اذا هو شرط
اساسي لاثبات ارتكاب الاباده الجماعيه وهو
ما عززته صحيفه الدعوه مشفوعا بالوقائع مع
الساعات الاولى لمئ يوم من القصف والغارات
قارب عدد ضحاياها 30 الفا تبار ارقام
المطمور تحت الانقاض نزعت تصريحات رسميه
اسرائيليه صفه البشريه عن اهل غزه تمهيدا
لقرار بحصار كامل قاتل ان خشم ان مازون لا
كهرباء ولا طعام ولا ماء ولا وقود لقطاع
غزه نحن نحارب حيوانات
بشريه هل كان جالانت يقصد افراد المقاومه
فقط يجيب الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق هيرتزوج
بعد ايام قليله بان المستهدف كل الشعب في
غزه تلك الامه كلها مسؤوله والقول ان
المدنيين لا صله لهم بالامر محظ افتراء
كان يمكنهم ان يثوروا ويسقطوا ذلك النظام
الشرير في
غزه واذا نصت الاتفاقيه على ان اخضاع
الجماعه المستهدفه عمدا لظروف معيشيه تهدف
لتدميرها يعتبر اباده جماعيه فان قائمه
الدلائل تطول كثيرا لتشمل مثالا لا حصرا
استهداف المستشفيات وكل مرافق الحياه
الاساسيه وقصف المناطق الامنه المفترضه
التي دعي المدنيون للنزوح اليها ثم
استهدفوا فيها على مدار يومي الترافع بدا
فريق جنوب افريقيا شديد الثقه في حجته هل
تعتقد شخصيا ان الاسرائيليين يريدون
القضاء على الفلسطينيين في غزه
لم تكن النيه ولا الافعال وحدهما ما
استندت اليه دعوه جنوب افريقيا ولكن ايضا
غياب اي عقاب قضائي او سياسي في اسرائيل
لمرتكبي الاباده الجماعيه او المحرضين
عليها جاءت ردود الفعل الاسرائيليه على
المحاكمه اكثر من غاضبه حتى وصفت تصريحات
المسؤولين في تل ابيب بالتشنج
والتجاوز اي وقاحه هذه نفاق جنوب افريقيا
صارخ
هل من ثمره عاجله ل مقاضاه اسرائيل امام
محكمه العدل الدوليه على صعيد الوصول
لادانه بشان الاباده الجماعيه قد يستغرق
الامر سنوات وفق قانونيين لكن جنوب
افريقيا في عريضتها طالبت محكمه العدل بان
تامر اسرائيل بالوقف الفوري لجميع هجماتها
العسكريه التي قد تشكل اباده جماعيه فهل
ستفعل المحكمه وهل تمتثل اسرائيل نحن الان